ok madonna cosa sto vedendo via via via
via via se mandare hamas e martin saprà
mai cosa gesù sto vedendo cosa aiuto
pietro madonna che male madonna che
schiaffi sto prendendo aiuto ai adesso
la morte abbia fatto uno stato maggiore
sono attivati tutti anche da chi sono
morto sono morti sono una volta per in
questo istante a meno che non mi muro
vivo ma non posso perdonare mi sono
morto dediti ragazzi il benvenuto che
somiglio sono file di soldati su
manfredi con pietro pietro 26 dove c'è i
quali non sono veloce le qua non c'è nè
importante bisogna farlo eccolo qua
perfetto bisogna bisogna fare i video
qua basta mettere le piante su dai
basta una targa poi questo puoi mettere
cosa storto
io ho girato questo gioco del gioco
dell'anno ma se dotata 20 tick la destra
20 di palestra gioco bello
dimmi chi dei due è gay parti barca
vuole andare per la barca è che leggono
anche al motore a quest ora me ne sarei
andato io figura di più tra l'altro è
bellissimo che poi c'è la mappa non ci
siamo mai pagata ma possiamo andare il
tuo casa affanculo stacca ok moglie anna
meyer
come puoi vedere dalla mappa che vedere
tutti nella mappa ci sono 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
quadratini
intorno all'isola che sono sette dungeon
ok quindi direi di andare oggi a fare un
dungeon perché finora ragazzi abbiamo
stiamo guardando la traversa scusate
finora ragazzi abbiamo scherzato cioè
senza abbiamo fatto questo
questa caverna che era il tutorial tra
virgolette adesso facciamo le cose serie
la notte amico oa una buona non quella
questa cosa che ti volevo dire l'ultima
volta che volevo dormire che buongiorno
andiamo prima di scegliere il dungeon
guardiamoci come i peggio guerrieri
perché non sappiamo cosa ci dici vento
per esata
prendiamo il cibo perché vi servirà
molto cibo allora visto che se una
persona non soffermare il grano questo è
il tuo cibo che ilo grazie a madonna 12
pezzi di panetteria chiudiamolo
tracciare fa basta farle youtuber
abbiamo panetterie allora come può
vederci sono quei sette dungeon quale
scegliamo per primo è quello partiamo da
più facile lava tempo io sta che i
cartelli rivolta che andiamo della serie
fatto è stato è stato poi non puoi
immergerti veci festa carioca qua sì ma
la si nuota ma che al vetro entriamo ma
spaccapietre come sono ancora accelerava
qua dentro
beh effettivamente sembrava cazzo di
sopravvivere senza aiuto di rare ma se
magari non mi dentri nel corpo ogni
volta dio buon che magari non mi è più
il corpo eccoci qua giorna fa mi sono
salvato c'è una certa grandezza togliti
dalle palle ma pantaloni diamante miei
miei ho trovati fantasma perché essi
sono bici gucci miei 40 di gucci found
di mucche 12 stordimento porca vacca
sotto c'è qualcosa a me mi piaci gante
sto posto i prof po più operano
io io l'ho esperto era piramidi qui sarà
probabilmente più piano ho trovato ho
trovato del ferro
mamma mia che disastro qua spacca un po
che per che scende tutta l'acqua
spero che muore chimiche morini che morì
di colori alkamar sia sopra viene sempre
questo vuoto
queste piena queste vuota basta
prenderle cell se tu allora mai iniziare
a rischio ucciderti
ci ho provato ma le abbiamo risolto dai
basta buona chiama che sono sfondi
qualcosa che è ottima lava ci sono i
nava in là ma cosi si daranno blaze
management e poi occhio nei lander o
chiude lander ok occhio che di salvo gli
serve e occhio all'occhio va bene
ammazzatelo ammazzatelo ti prego mazzate
pietro anche morte di molti morto a
mazzoli è morto
cav h m già che abbiamo era come se
fortissimi faccio fuori l'altro giu la
la mamma meno che in casinò e un altro
di scooter e stava sparando qualcuno ha
sparato perché molti cattivi si attiva
così lo re rispondere allora non lo so
lo spero ma continuano a suonare
non lo so lo spaccato a sparagli
chiamante sharpless 5 è fuggita
freddezza charms si fa più danno bene
controlla bene secondo me ce n'è ancora
un adagio porca vacca no no no non
volete con l'amore siamo all'anno zero è
finito già bene così torna su ora
proviamo a dove siamo usciti maledizione
la gara è una caso che sono fuori ma
iniziano al city fuori tutto e invece no
velo su chi cazzo è primo ma mai pari
pari pari da bene il primo la mia è
finito ogni 8 e figlia un dungeon
lasciamo un commento su quello che è
successo
in questo caso direi pietro è rotto ok
e questo è il primo il primo dei dungeon
se riusciamo a fare le tante questo il
medium tempio romano poi giochiamo in
casa tempio romano
bye bye andiamo così direttamente
direttamente qui sempre acqua tutto con
titoli loot proprio temerari senza paura
che sei dentro insieme sono entrati tu
sei pazzo la messa ha fatto niente
allora se non mi entri nel corpo in tre
secondi capisco cos'è sta roba qua
i viola sono caduto nell'acqua sono
mostri ovunque ci sono
sebbene facciamo fuori che io so
distruggendo uno sfonderanno in questo
momento che è spacca andato hai fatto si
spacca lo spaccato dei perfetti effetti
torce così esatto non rischiamo di forza
nella tromba la modifica ma questi che
ci sono mai stati a roma ma che chiesti
charlie romano sto con una cesta cosa
c'è lì roma nostro posto guarda che
siamo completamente 1 al contrario dello
zar
vabbè ma siamo due gemelli allora apre
una porta potrebbe essere the walking
dead appena un attimo con dobbiamo
anzitutto al sicuro qui prima di prima
porta perché perché attenzione a uno
scheletro una volta che mi ascolti non
c'è che ci sono un miliardo di porte qua
che facciamo sembra oggi ma lo guarda
sono forte nelle porte entra a capri ha
fatto tutto quanto mai vuol dire
sembrata cashes cast per regalargli che
entra in erba dal tetto dio a sky tristi
abbiamo due qualifiche dove sei quanti
anni hai o li ha fatti fuori sono dentro
o un arco con infinita 1 isole infinita
puoi dire che con una freccia spari
quante tracce voi nicchia tenchio però
finché non si fa allora anche le frecce
c'era già ce lo vogliamo vedere vedere
sharpless 5 quanto è forte
556 è tanto 5 è molto con una gran
fortuna
si è fatto e farò un attimo e proprio
gli under allora c'erano ben chiaro no
perfetto mamma mia quanto è forte questa
questa spada che mi ha trovate
fortissima dismessi ma non dobbiamo
perdere assolutamente
se c'è è inutile ma gli spieghi che
problemi c'è lo scheletro che ti sbagli
fatti vedere in faccia
stai bene o gemmabella c'era sì sì
subito un bello eh sì sei molto razza
benissimo direi che abbiamo fatto questo
white tempio romano abbia finito che poi
li romano ci aveva una sega sta roba
per ora almeno abbiamo buttato un botto
di roma e labirinto non trovo neanche
uscita eccola perfetto andiamo nel
prossimo
così dopo bonucci 6 sì perché si sentono
zombie comunque va vicino ma c'è una
caverna qua una caverna un'altra volta
una caverna dietro dietro del giardino
vieni vado e tanto ciardi
cosa ho visto così su madonna cosa ho
visto la riva arrivare l'arrivare
l'arenzano dietro occhio perfetto ok
ultimo mamma mia mamma mia quanta rieti
giro visto la morte quando sono entrato
qui ci sono anche grato quanta gente che
appena fisico di qua ma ne abbiamo
quindi l'ultimo questa roba addosso se è
ovvio che abbiamo tutti e due i d'angelo
dotati se moriamo son cazzi no spiega lo
spiega lo spiegano tranquillamente
perché diciamo ai nostri ragazzi che
cosa stiamo facendo perché siamo veri
uomini di allora visto che era troppo
facile questi ragazzi stanno giocando il
normal abbiamo messo il gioco nella
modalità più difficile che si poteva
mette perché noi valiamo pantene mamma
mia andiamo andiamo andiamo dove sei
finito
io sono tornato nel tempio romano
a regà bongiorno occhio non è che c'è
qualcosa quali nascosto ma vogliono
qualcosa mi piacciono sherlock holmes e
diamo no che per capire se invece ce
l'ha non cessa la scossa sopra la frutta
na3 diamanti pure te lo giuro tu rimani
cola no no no no more more
ciao pietro ma no ma che palle ma c'è
un'uscita così basta non lo sapevo non
hanno capito starò la via maledizione
non vale
stavolta veicoli delle forze mi hai
colto impreparato stavolta aveva non
vale un quarto decisamente primo
sportivo
niente a me lo sta canestrale sì questa
toccate posizionare il cartello anche la
lega bongiorno ok perfetto
abbiamo anche il secondo il secondo
commento secondo adagio infinito ne
mancano 5 ancora uno io lo farei
diamo siamo potevo fare ora e direi hard
non sono è difficile ma iniziare male ci
ammazzano e difficile vero giura è molto
difficile licola che airone di tutto
easy porca vacca di qualità che sono
quelle difficili questa ricerca nello
zucchero possiamo andare a vedere per
curiosità non aspetta cresce darli anche
se quest'acqua collard andiamo attimo a
vedere la casa perché mi dicono ecco
l'adagio che anche questa è albero il
tempo della strega che mi incuriosiva la
costruzione vedi agricola sito ok ci
saranno un botto di allenamento e rodi
allora aspettano fermo e il titolo
kickback per il prossimo episodio quindi
no niente casa prossimo episodio casa a
sono una persona per phila veniamo qua
jungle tempo perché se tu mi inglobi
ogni volta porco alla vacca è ok
madonna cosa sto vedendo via via via via
via sanno andare alla se parteciperò mai
come gesù sto vedendo cosa aiuto dietro
a madonna che male madonna che schiaffi
sto prendendo aiuto ai adesso una volta
mia persona morta tre giorni fa la
figura di tutti quanti sono morto sono
morto morto sabato a santa maria in
questo istante a meno che non mi muovo
vivo ma cosa per curarmi stramorto sono
vi sono i braccianti noi sul no non ci
posso credere
sì vostro credo non ci voglio credere
non ci credono tu non sai come ho fatto
a sopravvivere con ora dovrò rivedermi
questa parte tutta la vita non è delhi
come ho fatto a sopravvivere
no non sanno nato annuncia idea no
veramente non ti so spiegare a te lo
giuro e se ci sono roba incredibile c'è
mi hanno spinto fuori sono rimasto a
mezzo cuore è sollecitare di salire
senza che mi colpissero di nuovo sono
vivo cerea roba incredibile non sono
affatto essere viva assurdo 26 più tra
l'altro che sono all'entrata che ho
fatto dice di fortino si spegne come fa
cioè io non so come ho fatto a
sopravvivere non sono anche come hai
fatto tu devi sempre sul quale sono
chiuso vabbè ho fatto ho fatto una
cassettina ma che palle o mi chiama se
vuoi neanche uscire pieno di scheletri
dove sei tu e sono allentarlo dove
riformando la ministra indici più sotto
18100 della polini nell'acqua mamma mia
il disastro pietro
morimoto torchia ma è difficilissimo te
lo giuro cioè come scendi di choc
sono uscito è uscito prima con un cuore
ancora il numero di salvo per accumulo e
difficili già perché qualche trovato una
scelta con una cosa di diamante assurdo
e sei tu
sopra il dungeon c'era una scelta
pietro aiutami pietro dove cazzo mamma
mia che male che è male che male che
male che male che male che male che vada
alla fine ci rimango ci rimango è vario
sono carini e mezzo a cuore ancora
allora facciamo una nuova vini come mi
sento
salvo per un niente ogni volta per un
settore quando quando riguarderà il
video te lo giuro si vede io che vicino
a minchiate è spacciato come come morto
referente sono già cadavere invece
sopravvivo per non so che cosa
e qui entra qui dentro la qualità e
prezzo a grosso e un porco scritto
praticamente in tra cui dire no non è il
ieri mar da lì a spendendo
recuperabilità guarda che anche se non
stop
ciao amico ai bisogni di flash ciao sono
l'uomo per volete frecce grazie sempre
con quanta gente c'è europea no all arco
dove l'ho messo porca vacca è una
presenza freccia però io io una freccia
celoria e altre le ho addosso ma tipo
veloci e pieno c'è la durata di qualche
file pd ma quanti sono
mamma mia che male ai topi come sta
andando a fare qualcosa mi sta fermo
tutto il giorno oppure possiamo di qua
poi nome mi chiami pieno di scheletri
bakkali spaccare la faccia
ok sono sento un po stanco vantaggio
bene ora il tasto fatte ci sono sceso
conosciuto nora che a molti non trovai
ma quanti sto casino
continua ma che dico bene andrò via
intervento perfetto l'effetto occhio
sopra quanta gente
arianna sopra ecco che pone anche il suo
progresso basta ma quanta gente in giro
solo provare tutto giorno l'haka donne
che male come questo ci ha poi cantato
oppure no
chiamare l'ires ma se non sai come poi
c'è un sacco mario un solo morto io
muoio tumori non ho mai rimasto centro
un cuore
stavolta mi sa che non mi salvo stavolta
la miss angola mi sa di no ho preso
l'arco amico flavio largo quello giusto
e adesso sono cazzi x tutti o anche
l'acqua quello che è stata fece infinite
quindi ok capissimo dove la gente prima
che suoni ma non in spalla non così in
fretta si spoon e maledetti estrema sono
tanti questo scendendo sono box sul
posto sono poi ci aspetta amico io sto
tenendo la situazione di un'opa vada
però si capisce che è difficile muoversi
di sopra ok ci sto mettendo torce buona
facendo lavoro ne facevo io qui sì però
mi chiedo poi a quanta esperienza c'è in
giro pressi madonna quanto sia pieno di
frecce occhi giorno zombie didietro
stupito andato già belle scarpe di prada
e ci aveva quello
diamante ricavato equipaggiato quello
che è loro colpito dopo vietti ha capito
o no manuale fanno male fanno molto male
io sto coprendo come posso che forse è
successo che bug è successo niente nella
bocchio cercare di coprirti come posto e
macello europei diamanti altro titolo
ben diamante l'area occhi a uno qua dove
anche non solo d'occhio che devo tenerlo
più preme porre due robot in diamante
sono qui sono qui capito da mi dà il
pane ti prego brandita sto morendo e
mite l'intervento di internet
madonna non hanno visto cosa fa con il
suo salvato su cagato addosso c'è stato
un jobs che in maniera veloce 134 no
sono morto quando erano tutti morti
ormai l'ultimo mi uccido cinema 1 è
sparato da porca di quella mano dove
sbarra è un cecchino eccolo l'ho visto
ho visto 4 2 con caja che valeva fatto
96 anche era implicito fortissimo
dovremmo aver finito quasi sono ben di
ebook è buono buono del conto comodo il
piacenza è stata una cella il raduno
degli scheletri porca vacca un'idea ma
mira gates ha praticamente vabbè dire
che possiamo uscire mi chiamo
perché disastro bastava facciamo così ma
c'è ancora un occhio oriente hanno
trovato adesso ad un altro occhio rienda
due l'altro avanti perché adesso e stavo
per uscire troppo due ceste che questo è
stato un casino se lo fossero visto è
stato veramente bello come d'angelo però
questo come dovi nominiamo col commento
io do vinho bene così ok per come
nominato mezzo cuore ok allora abbiamo
fatto ce ne mancano di base la mia fatti
tre ne mancano 4 mancano water tempo il
tempio dell'acqua incolta media il
tempio guarded che dopo è che nelle
guardine il mio guardie le guardie non
lo so però non lo vedo neanche
disturbato da sotto tanto sotto ok
allora niente come carta inferiori
guardie potete pretendere guardie la
casa e il dragon slayer che non c'era
anche la difficoltà della notte è quindi
spero che vi sarà tutto noi oggi
concludiamo qua
grazie pietro per avermi salvato tre
volte alla porta sono morto però non
potevo salva l'inter
io metto l'occhio del lander qua che ne
abbiamo gia morto ok non mi ricordo
quanti ne sarò forse ad essere uno
addirittura 8 sarà infatti secondo me
siamo quasi già forse no non fosse
qualcosa di più buono mi ricordo che
vedremo bene
vabbè dai per adesso va bene aspetta le
mucche
a posto e carina di mucca no2 dimessa la
bocca emesse vicino agli altri perché se
l'assessore ci si nega ma bravo è bravo
style interi ma dai maiali
casini ha persi dai con un piano tattica
voli bravo però siamo tutto mischiamo
tanto oramai marsi razza l'ha fatto ma
accettiamo qua e non citiamo gli animali
e mian citiamo di tutti questi animali
perfetto adesso sta facendo e sta
emancipando gli animali ok quindi anche
the same animalista di mente
perfetto allora dai denti mostra
emancipando tutti gli animali devono
stare nel recinto qui ma la regola la
regola vale per tutti quanti gli animali
smettere
lord smettila di importunare quei
maledetti polmone spero ragazzi dice
cose sono poi che mi piace nel prossimo
episodio andremo nella casa questa qua
subacquea che è la casa che secondo me
tutti state aspettando sin dall'inizio è
una volta fatti tutti del genere con
slay però ci siano presenti
beh ragazzi
aiutatemi a bene arriva arrivare al top
metri con blocco dare il tocco lei store
questo dovrebbe bastare fino a domani ma
come buona grado ciao
[Musica]